Це дасть декілька іноді дуже дорогоцінних секунд... Поки він його ламає…
У наметовому містечку біля Верховної Ради готуються до вірогідних нападів з боку поліції.
За останні 24 години тут перебувало, за різними даними, від 200 до 300 людей.
Деякі - у масках, аби поліція не розпізнала тих, хто витягнув Міхеіла Саакашвілі з авто СБУ у вівторок.
Керує будівництвом захисних споруд у цій частині табору Олегз Київської області.
Він прийшов у наметове містечко ще ужовтні,
коли Саакашвілі оголосив про безстрокову акцію протесту.
Олег - учасник Євромайдану 2014-ого, зараз - прихильник екс-президента Грузії.
Для того, щоб ми перемогли корупцію. Для того, щоб ми прибрали владу, до якої немає довіри в українців.
Охорона Саакашвілі запевняє, що він мешкає у цьому наметі під номером 40,
увесь день відпочивав після ранкової спроби поліції розігнати табір.
У Генпрокуратурі політик з'являтися поки не має наміру.
Намет протестантів виглядає приблизно так. Подекуди вже виникли проблеми з дровами.
Без тепла тут може бути важко.
В цьому наметі- мешканці Одеси, яким сподобалося те,
що Саакашвілі робив на посаді губернатора регіону.
Ці чоловіки - або ветерани АТО, або тимчасово не працюють, є навіть підприємці.
Загалом тут представники як мінімум 12 регіонів країни.
Люди кажуть, що фінансують своє перебування у Києві самі.
Багато хто підтримує швидше не самого Саакашвілі, а його вимоги.
Перевибори або, мабуть, імпічмент. Він, швидше за все, вже актуальний.
Якщо ми воюємо з країною-агресором, а президент з нею торгує, то це якось некрасиво.
Більшість протестуючих- чоловіки, але є й жінки. Волонтерка на прізвисько "Ембер" з Кривого Рогу.
Відповідає за оборону табору, може надати і медичну допомогу.
Жінка тут не на підтримку Саакашвілі.
Насамперед вона приєдналася до вимог громадських організацій,
які були висунуті владі ще у жовтні.
Антикорупційний суд, зняття недоторканості з депутатів і, звісно, відкриті виборчі списки.
Чому відкриті виборчі списки? Ми хочемо бачити, хто йде до влади.
Не всі учасники впевнені, що їхній протест призведе до масових акцій,
хоча багато хто знає, що рівень соціальної напруги в суспільстві високий.
Якщо нас тут не буде, усі будуть сидіти вдома і чекати, коли ж за них хтось щось зробить.
Максим брав участь у Євромайдані й не хотів би повторення тих кривавих подій.
Він просто прагне, щоб влада виконала вимоги тієї революції.
І, як багато хто тут, готовий стояти далі.
Попри дефіцит палива, перебої з водою і геть не ресторанну їжу.